And now the old scout master.
We had a group camp and we got to this campsite and it was a really beautiful sort of lush campsite next to a river.
We had a great weekend. I borrowed a tent. We put the tent up,
Had a bit of difficulty hammering some of the pegs in because the ground was quite hard.
Instead of using the small rubber mallet, I borrowed a four pound mallet from one of our neighbours, hammered the tent pegs in without any hassles,
Had a great weekend. There was a troop of monkeys in the forest across the stream and they were sort of coming to camp every now and then and we chased the monkeys away.
We had a lot of fun exploring the area.
Time comes to pack up and I'm pulling tent pegs out of the ground and I pull one out and get hits in the face by a spray of water
And at this point I realised hammering it through a plastic water pipe which ran through the middle of the campsite.
It's the fastest I've ever seen a tent move, because now this tent was being filled with water. so we put the tent up and ran away with it.
But we were in quite a small town and in rural South African towns there isn't a plumber available on a Sunday afternoon to attend to these things.
So the campsite warden asked if I wouldn't mind leaving the tent peg there so that he could seal up the hole with it.
And I'm not sure what came after that, but I hope the end result was that they buried this water pipe a little deeper, because a plastic water pipe forages underground in the campsite seems like a race.
You have to be giving credit for being able to find that water pipe.
And he was told that if there was a water dowsing badge or water divine badge, there wouldn't be the chin.
It was a picture.
Well, welcome back to the Scout Master Podcast. this is Clark Green.
You're going to hear more from my friend Peter LaRue, who you heard just before the theme there a little bit later on, but we'll get to that in a moment.
Heard from Frank Maynard this week.
He says nice interview with Hab Butler on the development of the Journey to Excellence program.
It's good to know they just didn't pull numbers out of thin air.
When I first heard about the Journey to Excellence I was skeptical that we were going to go back to the same arbitrary numerical system that the quality unit used before the four centennial quality unit years,
But after seeing the worksheets I realized a lot of thought went into it.
Hab summed up what the program is all about.
Units that do scouting the way scouting is done will have no difficulty earning high marks in the Journey to Excellence.
Any shortcomings in one or more of the categories are leading indicators of what needs improvement in the unit,
And right now is a good time to run your own unit's numbers so far this year and see how you're doing, while there's time to work on anything that needs attention.
Well thanks, Frank. that's a good comment
And it's indicative of the different feedback I've gotten about the Journey to Excellence program and kind of reflects my own feelings about it too.
Very positive thing.
If you didn't listen to last week's podcast, we were talking with Hab Butler, who is a regional vice president for the BSA and was the chair of the Journey to Excellence development working group.
He had some things to say about the way that things were developed and what the hopes are for that program.
I also heard this week from Tony Rotol.
Tony is from Troop 457 in Cordova, Tennessee,
And he wrote in to tell me a little bit about his dad,
And his dad is up there in St Charles Illinois,
A little farther north,
A lot farther north,
And his dad's, with Troop 13, was with Troop 969 in Chicago for about 50 years.
Tony is rightfully proud of his pop there and said that he finally convinced him to start listening to the podcast.
So, Ted, hello.
Nice to meet you,
Ted Rotol, up there in St Charles Illinois,
And Tony said hi too. by the way,
Today on the Scout Master Podcast, we're going to talk with Peter LaRue.
Peter is a group scout leader in South Africa and he also attended the International Jamboree this summer
And he is also the author of a blog about pioneering called Ropes and Polls.
Peter and I had a wide ranging discussion about a lot of interesting things. you know kind of comparing and contrasting what it's like to be a scout in South Africa
and what it's like to be a scout here, and the spoiler alert on that one is pretty much the same.
I really enjoy talking with international scouts because it just cements that idea of worldwide movement
and the applicability of all of these scouting principles wherever they happen to land,
And I'm anxious to get to the interview. So let's get started, shall we
Music
Today on the Scout Master Podcast. I'm very happy to welcome Peter LaRue from South Africa.
Peter LaRue, that might be a familiar name to some of you. he's the author of the Ropes and Polls blog,
A blog that principally concentrates on pioneering, but we get to see some interesting things about international scouting
and scouting in South Africa. How are you today, Peter?
I'm good. thanks, Clark. I've had a great day so far.
It's Saturday here. it's Saturday there, am I correct?
Yeah, it's Saturday evening
And springtime there. yes,
Yeah it is. We had the first rains of the season this week,
So it's springtime, but you had a bribe, a barbecue, this afternoon,
So it's been a pretty warm day.
So tell me a little bit about the area that you live in, because I'm still amazed by this, Peter.
I'm still amazed that I can get on the computer and speak with somebody in South Africa in real time.
basically halfway across the world
There's a town called well, a city called Bononi, which is about 30 kilometers away from Johannesburg,
and it's really a continuous urban area.
There's about 9 million people that live in the urban area around Johannesburg.
At the same time, I'm also right on the edge of that area,
So if I'm half an hour driving in one direction, I'm in the middle of the city
and in the other direction I can be in a nature reserve,
So I'm very lucky. in terms of scouting,
It's very easy. Our local campsite is a 10-minute drive away
and then half an hour down the road I can be out in the real backcountry felt areas.
What does that look like?
Most of the time when we see South Africa on the television or something like that,
it's lions and grasslands and things like that.
Is that what we're thinking of?
Well, where I live, it's mostly open, flat country.
In fact, where my house is, there are a lot of wetlands around,
So there are a few lakes and marshes.
There's not a lot of trees here,
It's mostly crossland.
Like I said, the area where I live is 9 million people living here.
In terms of wildlife, there's not a lot of big animals around still,
except in place names.
There's an elephant fountain and a lion river and that sort of thing.
But in terms of big wildlife, there are some antelope around, things
like porcupines and otters, owls, eagles,
But on the whole, as much as my scouts like to joke with people,
the on-lines walking down the street,
Well, except occasionally, maybe, Who knows?
Yes, well, there was a hyena that came into the suburbs around here a few years back,
But of course, as much problem as it would if a cougar came into the suburbs
in Florida. I suppose
What's your role in scouting there in South Africa?
I am a troop scouter,
Not only in Grayspear. we have two troops in my scout group.
We have a boy troop and a girl troop.
Scouting has been open to girls to join what was formerly the boy scout movement
for about the last 15 years.
So we have two troops, two separate troops
At the moment. we do a lot of activities together
But I have about 24 boys in four patrols and we meet on a Friday night
And you do basically the type of thing that scouts do everywhere.
Yes, I mean it seems, having spoken to a few scouts from actually from Pennsylvania,
that our programs are very similar.
Basic terminology might be different
And the things, the emphasis on things, is a little different.
You know, when my guys learn about survival situations,
they don't learn much about, say, surviving in the snow,
And we deal with local conditions.
But on the whole our program would be recognizable to your scouts.
One event that you featured on the blog that is just fascinating to me
and that is the Contiki camp that you guys do annually.
What is that all about?
I think it was in the early 50s,
For Hayadol, who's a Norwegian anthropologist,
had this idea that he could recreate the journeys that the Polynesian islanders used
to travel from island to island,
And he had this idea of building a raft out of Balsawood
and sailing at 4,000 miles across the South Pacific,
And in fact, a lot of the people who joined him on their journey were former scouts.
And in the mid 1960s, there were a few scouts from South Africa who liked the idea
and they built a raft and they spent 24 hours living on this raft
on one of the bigger dams in South Africa.
And then, after that, in the early 1980s,
they picked it up as a pioneering competition in our province,
And every year, between 70 and 100 rafts take part in the competition,
which is part of it is about living on the water on a raft that you've built for 24 hours.
But then, on top of that, there's always a theme,
so you have to decorate your raft to match the theme.
So, for example, in 2011,, the theme was Contiki goes to Rome.
So you had rafts decorated like chariots, like Roman temples.
You had scouts dressed up in togas and with wreaths on their heads
And that's what they do.
It is the biggest annual event in South African scouting
And it's a lot of fun.
A lot of troops who take part spend the better part of the year preparing for it,
And people like I say: when you're spending 24 hours living on your raft,
you concentrate on time your square elections properly.
It is absolutely fascinating.
It's something that I would just love to try.
And how many rafts did you say participant?
I think the most we've had is around 120..
This last year, I think there were 70 teams.
Wow, I mean, that's just huge.
And so everybody is floating on this impoundment on this lake
And that is I'll tell you. I'll have a link to a couple of Peter's posts
on his blog about the Contiki thing.
You got to see it.
It is just amazing
If I could get my fellows to South Africa with a raft.
Well, hey, that's not a bad idea.
That is just a really cool idea.
We actually have a BSA troop at the American School in Johannesburg
and they participate this year.
So there is a small BSA involvement in Contiki.
I think this year was the first time there,
But, speaking to the troop scout, they'll need to be back next year.
We talked a little bit about the fact that you have scout troops.
You have cub groups as well.
Tell me about the group concept.
You said that you're a group scouter
And that's unfamiliar to us here.
How does that work?
The structure here is that we have scouting groups in three age groups.
We have cub scouts from 7 to 11..
We have scouts from 11 to 18..
And then we have rover scouts,
which is roughly equivalent to venture scouts or velocity teams
from 18 up to 30-ish.
So those branches are generally in South Africa
would all be members of a group.
So a group consists of a cub pack, a scout troop
and optionally a rover group.
So I was a cub at Nantes Benoni
Cub pack and when I left cubs
I naturally went on to the scout troop at Nantes Benoni
And that is generally how scouting works in South Africa.
Every cub pack is attached to a scout troop,
Every scout troop is attached to a cub pack
And that group committee forms sort of carries out
a lot of the functions of a sponsoring body in other movements.
So if you're sponsored by a church or a school or whatever,
then those functions are carried out by the committee
in terms of maintenance and administration,
looking after the property and that sort of thing.
I'm fascinated by the group concept
because I think there's many things that recommend it
And I think it's something that we should study here
and see if there's some aspects of it we should adopt.
You've described a rather smooth transition into a scout troop
and that's something that we worry over quite a bit here in the States.
Do you see that
Roughly what percentage of boys and girls from a cub pack
end up in scout troops in South Africa?
I would imagine
I don't know of hand, but on the whole
I would say it's probably between 80 and 90 percent.
that would come through smoothly.
That's an enviable percentage for us.
You compared rovers to explorers or varsity scouts
or venture scouts.
All of our youth programs pretty much stop at age 21..
But rovers can be rovers into their 30s. you say
I think globally the idea with rovers
I mean in other countries they said the limit is around 25..
Historically here there hasn't been a limit.
if you invest as a rover
as long as you are invested as a rover before you turn 35,
you can stay a rover forever.
That's historically been what's happened here.
But in terms of recruiting new rovers
it becomes a different proposition
to try and recruit a new rover into the crew
when the rest of the crew is 50 or 60 or 70,
because an 18-year-old might not feel he has anything in common.
So that's why the age limit's being bought in.
The idea really is that rovering is covering that part of your life
when you're leaving home, setting up your career,
getting married, starting a family,
and it's to help you apply scouting principles to your life
through that period.
And specifically for people who feel they don't have
the inclination or the time to be a troop scout or a pack scout,
So they don't necessarily want to be involved
with running a troop,
but they do want to stay involved in the movement.
That's who it serves.
I was in Switzerland at Kandersteg this year,
Met a lot of rovers
Again, something that I think would be a very interesting aspect
of scouting that's pretty much unknown here.
People do tend to stay involved,
but you kind of cross the Rubicon into this adult leadership world.
It's just a different way of looking at things
and a different way of experiencing the program.
You attended the
Which international jamboree? what number was it? this year
It was the 22nd,
The 22nd international jamboree, and that was in Sweden. yes,
That's right.
And so tell me a little bit about that experience.
For me it was a fantastic experience.
We,
Our contingent- all in all from South Africa
was 135 people,
of which 105 were scouts,
12 were unit leaders
who were traveling with the three scouts-
The three scout troops
And the remainder were ISD
International Service Team and then contingent staff-
And we joined 40,100 other scouts
in Kristianstatt, which is in the south of Sweden,
for the jamboree.
The jamboree itself was 12 days long.
Prior to the jamboree
we traveled in Germany for a week.
We were hosted by the DPSG,
who's the Catholic Scout Association in Germany,
And we then spent three days
on home hospitality
living with scout troops in Denmark.
The four patrols in my troops stayed
in three different towns for that,
but that was also quite an experience to see.
So we got to experience a bit of German scouting
and Danish scouting
and then got to meet everybody else at the jamboree.
What do you take away from an experience like that?
It must be just an incredible opportunity
to get a real interesting look
at scouting throughout the world.
One of the things that was very interesting
for a lot of us is we came away from it
realizing how similar our programs are.
I got to speaking.
I had long conversations with.
we had neighbors from Denmark
and a few people from Belgium.
I spoke to some Australians
and some American scouts
And to realize how,
although historically and culturally
and in terms of background
were quite different,
that the scouting principles are very similar
And, more important than that,
that the ideals of the promise and law
are so similar around the world
And that, although at times
there was a language gap
and there was difficulty in communicating,
we were all there with the same intention
And that was something
that a lot of my scouts remarked on as well.
And I think, if you look back to
when Baden Powell had the idea
of a chapter, this idea of
people learning
to cooperate
internationally was a big part
of why he did it
And that came through very strongly
for my scouts and for me.
It would be difficult to hold a stereotype
or dislike people who you've
spent a couple of weeks camping with.
I mean, that was really
his intention, I think.
And I think that was
the first time across for us,
whereas I think there were 156 countries
represented at the Jamboree.
So for most of my scouts
and I'm sure a lot of other people,
it was the first time they made someone
from Bhutan
or from South Korea
or from Brazil
or Italy.
So it was a really good opportunity
to get to know those people better.
We found that when we traveled to
the background
An immediate, shared way
of looking at the world
that kind of surpassed any differences that we had.
One of the great stories
from the Jamboree was
at the opening ceremony
there was an arena
which was sort of
a little valley
off to the one side of the campsite
and at the bottom of the valley was a stage
and we all sat on the slopes
of this valley facing the stage
and 40,000 people had to move
from the sub-camps in their campsites.
and speaking to the police
officers off to it who were there
to provide safety, they said they were
so surprised that
40,000 people got to this
opening ceremony and stayed for the concert
and got back off to it. so there wasn't a single
incidence of violence
or a disagreement or anything like that reported
and the police
were really surprised because they never dealt with that
in a public gathering-
all in Sweden There's always
a scuffle that breaks out somewhere-
but because all of these people,
with 40,000 of us, were there for the same reason
and we were all making friends
and trading badges
and being there. for the same reason,
it went very smoothly.
Obviously, you described a trip
that took about a month
altogether. Yeah, three weeks,
21 days out of the country,
and you had to travel
a pretty respectable distance
to get there.
Yeah, I think our total
travel distance was
in the region of 22,000 km
there and back. The interesting thing
is, for some of my scouts
who had never traveled outside
the country before, it was their first time
flying on an aeroplane,
their first time flying
or their first time traveling on a ferry,
their first time
traveling in an underground train,
their first time on a tram, which we did in Berlin.
so it was really
a big
whole new world of experiences
for them. It was probably a bit costly
as well, wasn't it? In today's exchange rate,
$3,500,
purchasing parity wise,
it's a significant amount of money
in South Africa.
It was quite
an expensive trip.
That's the interesting thing. there were some great stories
from our contingent.
one of the boys in my troop
phoned into a local radio station
and won a general knowledge competition
and that paid
for half of his trip.
One of the boys sold hot dogs
outside a shopping centre
for two years to pay for his trip,
and then
one of the girls in my troop was also
able to get sponsorship from local companies
and she went around from company to company
with a letter explaining
what Scouting did for the community
and what she was hoping to do in Sweden
and sponsorship for the entire troop.
the overall point being,
if you are a scout
or a scouter, you really must
find one of these opportunities
and take advantage of it.
It is a life changing experience
and it's not limited to
the world jamboree
or something like that. There are
many, many different opportunities
for international events
and travel for scouts,
For any scout pretty much going
to be the highlight of his time in scouting,
Absolutely. I mean
we've had in the past.
I've had scouts from our troop attend
the American national jamboree.
we've had scouts
from other countries-
I know definitely Germany-
attend Kontiki. here
we have another event which is
a 12 day
hike adventure in
the Cedarburg in South African.
a lot of international scouts
come to that as well
and it really is.
I know those scouts are still in touch
with people they meet when they were here
and it's a great chance
to see the world
and to see the world with people, to see the world
the same way that you do.
So my message for folks listening in:
it may seem difficult and expensive
and in many respects,
yes, it can be difficult and expensive.
it's a lot of arrangements to make,
a lot of things to do
and it's definitely something
that you should set your sights on,
if you can manage it at all,
and everybody can manage it.
it's just how you go about it.
what happens in
coming months in your scout group?
The next big event we have coming up,
is the next big international event,
which is the jamboree on the internet
and jamboree on the A,
which is the 14th and 15th of October.
we always have a camp
at our local campsite
and we also have some radio amateurs
who help us
get onto the radio waves and speak to scouts
from all over the world.
that's the next big thing we're doing.
and the other thing-
believe it or not, although it's in September,
we are looking forward
to contiki in march and preparing for that.
I have a lot of young scouts,
so there's a lot of training we have to do:
making sure everybody
is able to tie the mashings
and assemble the raft,
able to handle the raft on the water,
getting everybody through their
swimming proficiency badges
so it's safe for them to be on the water
and we are
probably planning
a hiking trip in December.
Tell me a little bit about the way
the youth leadership concept works
in South Africa. I imagine it's
somewhat similar. Do you have,
for instance, a senior patrol leader
in that type of thing?
In the South African Scouts Association
we called it a troop leader.
we then have
patrol leaders
and patrol leaders have an assistant patrol leader
and
the goal is
for those patrol leaders and the troop leader
to be driving the program
and running the troop meetings,
much as it is in the
BSA system.
at the moment I have
some new patrol leaders
because I had three of my scouts
age out and turn 18 in the last
two months.
so their former
assistants are now training up for the job
and they are doing a pretty good job.
but they do need
a bit of a helping hand every now and then.
but the idea in the course of a meeting is that
they well, in the course of
a year they will tell
me and my assistants
what it is they want to do in the meetings
and we will help them put that together.
and then in the course of a troop
meeting I will issue
instructions to the patrol leaders
and they will then carry those back to their patrols
and as far as possible
they do
all the training and all of the
instructing and all of the running
of the program.
I'm sure, as it happens here, that they do just a
flawless job.
there's never any problems, difficulties,
setbacks or anything like that.
one of the things
I try to
remind them is that
the point of
being a patrol leader is to learn
how to lead,
because sometimes I think it's difficult
when you are 14
or 13 and you're trying as hard as you can
and things don't work out because
you haven't quite understood the dynamics
of your patrol. but I try
always to encourage them and remind them
that they're doing-
probably doing a better job than they think they are-
and
just help them identify what hasn't worked.
just thinking back- I saw you had a blog post this week
about that black bulb or a harm moment
when you see a scout realize something.
and for me one of the great things
is when I see a patrol leader
understand how this
member of the patrol who they don't quite
get on with or who never quite listens to them,
when they understand
how to speak that person's language
and get them to cooperate,
and when I see that patrol
certainly mesh together and see that the patrol
leader's understood what he's got to do.
that's quite a rewarding thing for them
and for me as well.
Okay folks, so we're talking halfway across the world,
same thing happening,
same exact thing happening.
because I think sometimes we get our heads down
in our own concerns,
in our own scout troops,
and we don't think that
anyone else is experiencing
either in the way of difficulties
or achievement or things like that.
but it's always a bit
of a reassurance
to know that this is
just the way things are.
I was speaking to scouts
from Belgium
at the Jamboree and we were just saying
laughing at how his patrol
leaders and my patrol leaders were battling
the same things in their patrols at the Jamboree.
and even if you
read, there was
a report done by the
Scouts Association in the UK
in the 60s or late 50s
called the
Advanced Report, and it spoke about
problems in the movement and the interesting thing
is that you can read that report and it's like it was
written yesterday.
The problems in the movement
are too much bureaucracy,
difficulty
attracting adult volunteers,
difficulty retaining Scouts
around the age of 13 to 14,
and these really,
I think in every country
and every time those are things we've battled with.
I could always do with an extra
assistant helping at a meeting.
I always noticed that
when Scouts reach that
9th grade
they find things
that are more interesting to them than Scouting,
and I always found myself filling in
more paperwork than I'd like to.
I think those are universal problems and it's reassuring
to know that it's not just
you that's battling with these things.
You know, I go back
and I look at what was being
said during
that kind of founding years of Scouting.
when it comes down to
opening the door and meeting with
your patrol leaders and watching
Scouts do what they do,
I don't think people who were involved at that
time would see too much that was unfamiliar
to them,
Absolutely. I mean, if I
read Age to Scout,
which was paid in Pal's book,
I can apply all of those things
directly to the way I'm on that trip today
and the patrol leaders
handbooks that were written in the 20s
are as applicable to the Scouts today as they were then.
Yeah, and it is
just a remarkable thing.
Now your advancement
program
culminates with
a Springbok Scout. is that correct?
That's right
And that is,
we would imagine is,
kind of equivalent to
Eagle Scout here. How's that looked at there
and how do you
manage that level of advancement?
It's certainly
a great achievement.
I think that the statistics are
roughly 1% of Scouts
who start as a Cub Age 7
achieve Springbok Scouts.
One of the things in our current
advancement program that works very nicely
is that the levels are all integrated,
so as a
in the first level of advancement
most of the advancement is
experiential things. You'd come to a true
meeting and you learn how to tie
knot or you learn how to deal
with the first aid situation. In the second
level of advancement
you are
more involved. you learn that in greater detail
and then, starting up into the high levels of advancement,
you start taking responsibility for
training your Scouts
in those things. and then finally,
at the Springbok Scout level,
you'd be responsible for planning
and putting together a camp for your whole troop
and
one of the things you'd look at on that camp
is making sure that all the advancement levels below yours
are receiving
their training and advancement that they need
in the course of that camp
and that vertical integration works really well
so that your patrol leaders,
in the course of running their patrol,
will be required to
in earning their own advancements
to help their patrol
members advance.
In terms of managing the whole process,
the Springbok Scout,
there are three particular
overseen
by the Provincial
Commissioner for Scouting.
so everything else in that advancement would be signed off by
me as a troop Scouter.
but one of them is a construction project.
and the second
of those three things is an expedition,
which is a multi-day hike
in
territory that's unfamiliar to you
and
you have to produce a log afterwards
and that log is examined.
and then the third thing is there's a community service
and service project component
which you're required to complete-
again
largely similar to,
I believe, a similar requirement for Eagle Scout,
and those are examined
and tested
by the Provincial Commissioner.
but everything else is handled
by the troop Scouter.
and the way you arrive
at Springbok Scout,
there are five advancement labels
and at the end of each advancement label
we have a personal growth agreement.
when you reach
the first class,
which is to
advance,
part of your personal growth agreement
is to sit down and do a proper
managed project, then
how you're going to achieve your Springbok Scout.
so it starts at that level
where you plan out
which merit badges you're going to do
and how you're going to
work your way through to Springbok Scout.
it sounds very familiar.
so well, I really appreciate you
spending some time with me and maybe we'll get to do it again someday.
is there anything I've missed
or anything you'd like to add?
I'll just remember,
as I say, Kentucky Structure as a pioneering competition
and
one of the things that happens
is that the top 10 teams
that have Kentucky are invited
to the Kentucky Chairman's Challenge
event.
normally that takes the form of a raft race,
about a
15 mile race down a river,
and this year
they did it a little differently
and the 10 teams that took part
in Chairman's Challenge this year had to start
at a campsite
near my house
and they built their raft
and put it onto the water
and did an obstacle course on water
and they had to dismantle their raft
and load it up on a track
and drive 20 kilometers
to another scout campsite,
build their raft again,
do some obstacles there,
and they did this four times over the course of the weekend,
traveling across the province,
starting here
on the east strand and ending on the west,
and along the way,
focusing on how the pioneering worked
at each campsite.
but also tracks had to be decorated
with scout badges
and to promote the movement
and they were given a few
scavenger hand sort of items
to pick up along the way, questions
to answer about the trip and that sort of thing.
so just speaking to some of the people
who went on that
and seeing the guys at the first base
near my house, it looked like a lot of fun
and something quite challenging.
we have a couple of ponds nearby.
we've talked about trying to scale
the whole contiki idea
into something that we could do there.
I mean, it just sounds like a tremendous amount of fun.
it ties in with so many of the other things
that you want to do anyway.
you know all the pioneering skills,
the camping skills, the swimming bit,
a really interesting scout event.
is English the principal language
in your area,
or are other languages spoken?
South Africa has 11 official languages
and
I only speak
two of them.
it's not unusual for people to be able
to speak four of them.
in the area where I live,
there are probably four languages
that most people
will speak. two out of the four languages:
English.
Afrikaans,
which is related
to Dutch,
is very similar to the dialect of Dutch.
Zulu,
which is an African language,
an indigenous language.
and Swana,
which is also an indigenous language,
which we also share with
Swana, which is one of our neighboring countries,
so most people
in my province will speak at least
two of those four languages.
largely
in urban areas most people
can understand English.
as you move out into the rural areas
it depends very much
on the part of the country
which language is the easiest to communicate in.
so you speak
English and Afrikaans.
that's right.
and let me ask a favor of you
and, if you'd be comfortable doing it,
if you could say the scout
motto in
Afrikaans and then in English.
so in English the scout motto
is be prepared
in Afrikaans.
in Afrikaans we speak
excellent.
thank you very much.
I followed the blog
and I was heartened to see your post about the
jamboree and all the
interesting pioneering that was going on there.
I'm going to definitely point everybody
back to
ropes and poles.
the other really fascinating thing I saw on that-
I guess it's been a while,
but it was the Israeli pioneering.
I would like to see that
up close Monday.
I'd like to give that a shot, actually
make a couple of those interesting projects
a giant hedgehog or something
that looks like a lot of fun.
I was hoping to see something like that at the jamboree,
but I guess
at the jamboree people
are more focused on
meeting the scouts
and holding gateways,
which is as it should be, I think.
well, I think
we went to Switzerland with big plans
and we left our
time open because it was our first trip
there and really didn't know
the conditions and everything,
and what we found was the best part of
the time we spent there
meeting with other scouts and talking
and to swap things.
yes,
absolutely.
we found
we had a fantastic trip in Germany
and Denmark.
where the trip really came alive for my scouts
was that they were in Copenhagen
and, as luck would have it,
we went down to the harbour
to look at the statue of the little mermaid
at the same time as the UK
contingent did,
and my troop-
the patrol I was-
was in my scouts,
but the UK contingent was 4,000 strong,
so we came around the corner and they were 4,000
scouts,
so you can find some trading
badges with each other on the streets,
you know. so
they were carrying with them
and they started trading them
and you know
little silver flags,
stickers and labels and everybody started
swapping things and it was completely
unplanned. we didn't know they were going to be there
and it just became a highlight
for my scouts. they were very excited to meet
all these people
and it was really
where the jamboree started for them.
that's quite a picture
I can imagine turning a corner
and, yeah,
all of a sudden running into
a few thousand UK scouts coming the other way.
they're pretty garrulous, those UK scouts.
the sun happened to be shining that day
and there were a few Scottish scouts
running around in kilts
enjoying the sun.
we were sort of walking through the old town
in the opposite direction,
in the opposite direction
from the UK scouts and at every traffic signal
when we'd stop there,
be on the other side of the road and we'd wave at each other
and salute to each other and shake hands
with the left hand as we crossed through
the intersection. and that happened
all the way down the street through the old town.
I will say again:
you got to make this happen,
it's at all possible.
get your scouts together,
figure out how to make it happen and get to
an international scout event.
you'll never, ever regret it. it's just so much fun.
on the strip I got to meet people
speaking to
the internet and on the radio
for five or six years
with the jamboree on the internet
and just to
to realise
we're part of a very big worldwide
brotherhood of 30 million people
is really,
really exciting and really inspiring for your home troop.
I've come back with so many ideas from people I've met
and so many people
that I can get my scouts in touch with
that. it really is something that's worth doing
and I mean, it's hard to seem to pull together.
I thank you very much for taking the time
to talk to me today
and we'll be watching
the blog.
great, thank you very much, Clark.
well, thanks for listening to this edition
of the scoutmaster podcast.
here's how you can keep in touch.
first of all, you can read the scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom.
while you're there, you can subscribe
to the scoutmaster newsletter,
a monthly digest to the scoutmaster blog
and podcast.
you can also subscribe to the podcast on iTunes.
when you do, feel free to leave a
comment or review or a rating.
you can also follow us at scoutmaster blog
on facebook and scoutmastercg
on twitter,
and you can email me
with your comments and questions
at scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
that's
scoutmastercg
at Verizonnet.
the scoutmaster blog and the scoutmaster podcast
are not official publications of the Boy Scouts of America,
nor are they endorsed
or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, it's just me
talking into a microphone
to lend a hand to scout leaders and maybe having a little
bit of fun along the way.
well before we leave you,
we need to hear from our founder, Sir Robert
Baden-Powell. Sir Robert,
I highly recommend
the scoutmaster podcast.
anything else,
good luck to you and good camping.
thank you, sir.
until next time
you.